i like the asian couple  i wasn't talking to you guys i was  talking about the white guy in the asian  girl  that's asian couple in orange county  they don't want to see two edges  together like  a lot of  break it up break it up it's like uh  what is it the gang over here what's  going on  there's gotta be one white in every  is this your first asian girlfriend  oh it's your wife  oh wow good for you  so ebay or  just 90 day fiancee or this  i'm just teasing  how long you guys have been married  10 years  wow  did he make you say it at any point in  the relationship  you know  what  me so hard me  [Applause]  look at him clapping he was like yeah  oh man  day three boy i like  just [ __ ] say it  [Applause]  i need